行ってきましたねこの季節がたまにこういうのがあるんですよね
今回もちょっと気になるインターネットの像がありました実際にそれをやってみようか
と思います
やってはいけない儀式というものがございます
必要なことは鏡4はろうそくを1本
注意してください
麦野そ時こう書くとは言わないよ
この鳥ほどマン陛下の見ると一辺の長さが15cm ほどの正方形になるように当財団
僕の位置に鏡を立てておいてください部屋の電気を消して夜の12時46分から
一致で13分までの27分間の間にか紙で作った正方形の真ん中に
ロウソクを立てて使用合わせ鏡の中にとても強いものが写るそうです
のってなんか試した人がいる選手を試した人がいるみたいなんですけどもショックで靴
が聞けなくなってしまい未だに鏡に何が映った彼は海はないらしいですやめましょう
なんでんかんやろーやるしかねぇだろう
今なんですよ残り15分後15分後に儀式ができる時間ありますので早速準備をして
いきましょうでっ
こっちっに
ナミーガシガシ知っとった坂上は4つ買ってきました
book 映ってでも人の顔が映ってねこれ抜けこれこれ取れちゃったって言っちゃ
んっ
びっくりしたはずでカーヌーンよと合わせカラー良くないんだよね真如中旬1
いきましたはっぴちゃん釣っちゃう3階と3階感じじゃなくなりまうんちゃう
5袋ルーフびっくりした定額25cm 図っていきましょうして
不明な
二番パパない作ってるれってルっててってはい出来ました大体こんな感じだと思います
だからこの真ん中にろうそくを落ちますただいまの時刻が例えば12:40あと7分後
に始まります行ってきまーこんなてぃんで怒られちゃう実際に何かが見えるかもしれ
ないけどやっていきましょーっブーバー今よ
はいあと10秒後です
いきません
いやいや待ってよずるくなったのまた分
いうわけだ好きさといっ
もっくん
うわーん
ず通用しそう
細くて見て泣くんじゃないんじゃないわ見えないねぇ
プーサ6
見れない上野3-1の意味がないし
ふう準備これで完成くらいの1ってよ
なんか聞いたんだけどさまじかため魚なんて組んだ
阿猪見ちゃった制度でみよせーの
う
見て見北杉岡まで自分が出てく
田丸からこの
浅谷まで繋がっている感じです実施機関誌から3分が経過しました
未だに大きな変化というのは見られないのでちょっとまだ何とも言えない
引き続き見ていこうと思います
メッツに行き印字するんだよ
5見えないよ
ございまーす
ああああハイッ
あ